well
[Music]
hello today is today November
5th 3 gonzález greet you and these are the
most relevant news of the day
after two days of the election all
eyes are on snowfall in the close
race for the presidency against the
vote count that  they are taking
place in clark county and in the state
to follow the latest results
visit news now dotcom
the director of the
elections department said this morning that the goal
is not to count quickly but to have a
correct count they affirmed that they had
a mistake  in the figure that was reflected
on their website but that this has
already been corrected and they will be publishing
new results today
and tomorrow for their part the secretary of
state of nevada revealed new
results many more are expected to be
published during the rest
For its part,
President Trump's campaign announced this morning that it would
file a lawsuit against
the county elections department.  Clark
for Voter Fraud Following Reports
of Vote Tracking and Vote Counting Anomalies
The lawsuit specifically says
that 10,000 people who are no longer
residents of the state managed to vote for
their part. Clark County officials
said they have no
knowledge of anomalies or problems.
city ​​council members from
across southern nevada are sponsoring
a virtual job fair
today it will be from 1 pm to 4:30 pm it
's free but registration is required
on the website you see on the
companies screen  in las vegas' north of las
vegas and henderson are looking for
employees
now let's see what awaits us for the
weekend in the temperatures today
we will have a maximum of 86 degrees for
tomorrow the winds arrive that will bring
cold for Saturday and with possibilities
of  rain for Sunday
the autumn temperatures are beginning to show so
they have to prepare for April to
stay well informed of the
news  most recent in our city, you
only have to visit our page
at noa dotcom in Spanish informed you by
andrés gonzález
[Music]